Next, we'll wanna drop in our overhead diffuser,
which will kind of act as our global stage light.
So this is gonna be our Chimera 10 by 30 foot
light white diffuser.
And this is gonna be within our collections
underneath the light stage.
So we'll jump back over to our scene.
And I'll go ahead and clear up my place actors,
go down to my collections,
and we're gonna look for our light stage.
And here is that Chimera 10 by 30 foot white light.
So I'll go ahead and drag this into our scene.
I'm actually gonna go up to the light stage,
I'm actually gonna go up into unlit mode real fast,
just so I can see placement.
We're gonna move this up,
kind of move this around, rotate it,
and move it into place.
I'm gonna press G to go into game mode.
And I'm gonna go to lit mode.
And now you can see we're actually starting
to get some effects.
Now it's important to note real fast here,
a couple of things that are occurring.
Because we are using Unreal Engine 5,
we have Lumen enabled.
So this light panel,
which actually doesn't have a light in it of itself,
but rather is using the material emissive properties
to cast light into our scene.
And then secondly,
because we are using DirectX 12
and we have those higher quality reflections,
you'll see that we start to see them
within the actual reflections of the vehicle.
And of course, any object that has anything
that's not rough, we start to see those reflections.
So again, no lights per se within our scene right now,
outside of just our skylight,
but rather just the emissive material
from this particular panel.
So with that being said,
we actually want to add a light into our scene.
And in particular, we're gonna be using
what is called a rec light or a rectangle light.
Now it's important to note that rectangle lights
are probably the most expensive type of light
that you can use in our scenes,
just because of the nature of how they're built.
And that is totally fine for what we're doing.
For real time applications,
I would say just be mindful
that if you're adding a ton of rectangle lights
into your scene,
that's where you may notice a dip in performance.
But again, for this scene,
we should be totally fine to add several rec lights
and still run fairly well.
So if I jump back to our scene,
I'm gonna go to our place actors.
I'm just gonna type in rect,
which will give me my rec light.
If you're curious too,
you can actually just click the little lighting
light button here.
And we can see here as a rec light,
get us to the same spot.
So I'm gonna drag one of these rec lights into our scene.
I'm gonna press G to go back into game mode.
And essentially what I wanna do
is just rotate this into place
where it's fairly aligned with our light panel.
So I'm just kind of setting this up a little bit.
And there are a few settings that I wanna change.
The first thing is we are setting candelas.
Here you can see that we can change exposure value,
lumen or unit list.
For this case, I will just continue to use it.
Actually, let's go and change it to lumens.
And then I wanna go ahead and set my intensity here
to 12,000 lumens, which should be fairly bright.
In fact, we can see that exemplified on the ground.
So we'll turn this off and on.
You will notice we have this preview shadows indicator
and that's because we are in stationary mode.
So again, all of our lights are gonna be fully dynamic.
So we'll switch it to movable.
All right, so I'll come back down here a little bit
so we can see what's happening.
So the next thing that I wanna do is adjust a few properties.
So the first is attenuation radius.
So if I drag this all the way down,
I can take a look here,
you'll see that this is effectively
the influence of that light.
So within this outer sphere,
this is the full extent or how far the light
can affect something.
So in this case,
because this is a very large primary source,
I'm gonna change our attenuation radius
to something like 2,500.
And you can see this encapsulates our entire scene,
which is exactly what we want.
All right, the next thing that I wanna do
is actually adjust the width and the height.
So the way that erect light works
is we essentially have these barn doors.
So if I kind of take this down, you'll see,
kind of like they're flaps,
they're doors on the side of the light.
But in particular, this main center square
that we have here,
this is essentially where the light is being projected from.
So we want to match that inner square
to essentially the projection zone
or where our light panel is.
So to do that, I'm actually gonna change
our source width to 850,
our source height to 240.
And you can see that I've actually got this rotated
90 degrees.
Let's go ahead and rotate this back.
And then again, I could go into here real fast
and just essentially try to get this aligned
to our panel as much as possible.
And that should be good enough.
There we go.
So this better, more closely matches
our actual Chimera panel that we have here.
And finally, the last thing is we could take
our barn door angle down just a little bit.
So we can set it to something like, for example, 55.
And we could, if we wanted to adjust our barn door lengths,
although in this scene, we won't particularly notice it,
but I'll go ahead and just set that to 40.
All right, cool.
So that should get us all set up on our light panel.
And then lastly, if we wanted to,
we could essentially just duplicate this light panel
to give us just a little bit more effect.
So I'm gonna take both of these.
So just hold down Shift and Select.
I'll move these up.
And you can see with our real world lighting values,
again, because we're using energy conservation
the way light works, is if I push this closer
to the surface, you'll see we get much brighter,
much brighter highlights of the light.
So I'll kind of move this up a little bit,
move this off to the side.
And then again, you could do Ctrl C, Ctrl V.
But in this case, with both my light and my panel selected,
I'm just gonna hold down Alt and drag off and duplicate.
So there you go.
Now we have some lighting that's occurring in our scene
that looks more natural.
I'm always gonna go back to my calibration tools
and find out, hey, this may be too bright.
I'm gonna go ahead and just select both of my rec lights.
And maybe what I do is,
I'm gonna go ahead and just deselect.
There we go, our rec lights.
And maybe instead of 12,000 lumens,
I drop these down to 8,000.
Compare against my calibration tools.
And you can see that, okay, we are sitting much nicer
and our results are actually speaking for themselves,
looking very good, very realistic.